the budget red box was raised outside
number 11 but it contained a narrative
that had largely been set by number 10
are you in charge with salmon's
chancellor known for his inclination for
caution charged instead with treading a
politically perilous path to demonstrate
the direction of travel on the prime
minister's promise to end austerity but
doing so on the assumption brexit talks
are heading towards a deal despite the
deep uncertainty over the ultimate
destination i know called the chancellor
of the exchequer
the right honourable Philip Hammond from
the outset the Chancellor claimed this
was a budget with the needs of the
British people at its heart a budget for
hardworking families who live their
lives far from this place and care
little for the twists and turns of
Westminster politics the strivers the
grafters and the carers who are the
backbone of our communities returning
time and again to the prime minister's
claimed that this was an end of an era I
could report to the British people that
their hard work is paying off and the
era of austerity is finally coming to an
end
pots of hundreds of millions were
announced for mental health the Ministry
of Defence Social Care counterterrorism
policing potholes and schools but the
big decisions on what government
departments will have to spend will push
back to next year's review meaning much
rests on the outcome of brexit
negotiations but we're at a pivotal
moment in our EU negotiations and the
stakes could not be higher get it right
and we will not only protect Britain's
jobs businesses and prosperity but we
will also harvest a double-deal dividend
a boost from the end of uncertainty and
a boost from releasing some of the
fiscal Headroom that I am holding in
reserve at the moment but there was an
acknowledgment that no deal could happen
and in addition to boosting the no deal
preparation warchest by 500 million the
Chancellor said he was ready to call for
a fresh budget in the spring if it was
needed we'll take whatever action is
appropriate if necessary upgrading the
spring statement to a full fiscal event
in terms of money raising measures the
most eye-catching was a new did
to services tax targeting firms like
Google and Facebook this will be a
narrowly targeted tax on the UK
generated revenues of specific digital
platform business models it will be
carefully designed to ensure it is
established tech giants rather than our
tech startups that shoulder the burden
of this new tax nods of approval from
the DUP for announcements of money for
Northern Ireland will have been a
reassurance to the Chancellor fearful
that losing their backing could see his
budget voted down but it was on
universal credit the government's
flagship welfare reform that he faced
the most dangerous threat of a tory
backbench revolt investments worth an
additional 2.7 billion perhaps enough to
see that off for now but there was a
clear refusal of Labour's demand that
the rollout be start Universal Credit is
here to stay we are putting in the
funding it needs to make it a success
and in a further step to sea off Tory
MPs concerned by the lack of tax cuts
the Chancellor brought forward plans to
increase personal allowances so I will
raise both the personal allowance and
the higher rate threshold to these
levels from April 2019
delivering our manifesto commitments one
year early a tax cut for 32 million
people 130 pounds in the pocket of a
typical basic rate taxpayer in his
response Labour leader Jeremy Corbyn
dismissed what he described as the
ideological tax cuts for the rich and
challenged the central premise of the
budget the government claims austerity
has worked so now they can end it but
that is absolutely the opposite of the
truth
austerity needs to end because it has
failed the SNP leader meanwhile accused
the Chancellor of failing to set out how
the UK would deal with breaks it
uncertainty the storm even never mind
the shelter we need this budget leaves
us wholly unprepared for the brexit
bombshell heading towards us it feels to
protect current and future generations
this was a budget where the Chancellor
was boxed in by the prime minister in
more ways than one
using giveaways over balance in the
books he's an uncomfortable choice for
the man who describes himself as fiscal
filth Tom Rainer Sky News Westminster